Trascrizione: Maksim Kamrysh
Revisore: Agnese Giacomelli
[Applausi]
I confini.
I confini non esistono.
E nei prossimi 10 minuti è di questo
che voglio provare a convincervi,
se riesco, se riesco a farvi venire con me
in questo viaggio, diciamo, spaziale.
Il desiderio di controllare e delimitare
l’ambiente in cui vive,
accompagna l’uomo
sin dalla notte dei tempi.
Le società moderne sono definite da
territorialità, stati sovrani,
confini netti e lineari,
ma soprattutto geologici.
E sottolineo, soprattutto geologici.
Io sono un geologo.
Studio fiumi e laghi sulla Terra e
su Marte e voglio pertanto invitarvi ad
adottare nei prossimi minuti
una prospettiva sia geologica che spaziale
nell'approcciare il concetto di confine.
Sin dal dottorato,
e quindi negli ultimi dieci anni,
ho studiato in particolare Marte,
un pianeta, dall’alto,
utilizzando dati orbitali, dati di Rover.
E questo mi ha permesso di
lavorare appunto su corpi dove i confini,
almeno per ora e per come li conosciamo,
su corpi dove i confini non esistono.
Sono un geologo, sì,
ma negli ultimi anni ho anche acquisito
una specializzazione in istituzioni
e politiche spaziali.
Per cui, sebbene sia consapevole che
potrebbe non essere così
e per sempre in futuro, il mio auspicio
è che lo spazio extraterrestre,
come anche i fondali oceanici,
ambienti che sono tra loro
per molti aspetti simili,
restino luoghi di pacifica cooperazione
tra gli stati
e che pertanto
non debbano conoscere
il concetto di confine come lo conosciamo
noi sulle terre emerse.
Se guardiamo al passato terrestre,
da sempre l’uomo ha voluto delimitare
lo spazio in cui vive
e in particolare le popolazioni indigene
hanno spesso usato i fiumi
come separatori tra le tribù.
I fiumi hanno da sempre fornito
agli antichi popoli vie di comunicazione,
nutrienti per le terre
attorno ai fiumi,
ma anche acqua potabile
e soprattutto vie di comunicazione.
Pensiamo a società come i sumeri e
i babilonesi, che si sono sviluppate
appunto lungo il Tigri e l'Eufrate.
Pensiamo agli antichi egizi
che si sono sviluppati lungo il Nilo,
pensiamo agli antichi romani
che si sono sviluppati sul Tevere.
Successivamente gli antichi imperi
iniziarono
ad erigere muri
per tracciare frontiere,
per separare i sedentari
dai nomadi,
per definire il dentro
e il fuori dell’impero.
Pensiamo che queste frontiere nei secoli
assunsero una funzione difensiva.
E pensiamo anche alla muraglia cinese
che vedete qui alle mie spalle.
Questa è un’opera che, pensate,
è visibile dallo spazio.
E rappresenta tuttora l’opera difensiva
più grande mai costruita dall’uomo
con i suoi 7000 chilometri.
Qualche secolo più tardi anche
gli antichi romani
iniziarono a costruire
immense frontiere,
la più grande delle quali è quella
che andava dalla Germania alla Scozia.
La costruì l'imperatore Adriano.
Finisce in Scozia con il famoso
Vallo di Adriano e fu voluta appunto
dall’imperatore per limitare l’invasione
dei barbari nell’Impero.
Nel XVIII secolo prima l’Impero francese
e poi la Repubblica francese
costruirono frontiere per delimitare anche
il dentro e il fuori dell’impero.
Sempre nel XVIII secolo,
e grazie a politici francesi,
iniziò ad emergere
il concetto di confine naturale.
E i fiumi furono i primi ad essere usati
come confini naturali.
E tutt’ora fiumi e montagne fungono
appunto da barriere naturali
che separano stati.
Tuttavia, nella storia dell’umanità
le frontiere hanno conosciuto
anche momenti di totale arbitrarietà,
come in Africa.
Siamo nel XIX secolo dove i confini netti
e lineari divisero un intero continente.
Oppure come recentemente,
nel XX secolo, un intero muro divise
un intero paese per ben tre decenni.
Nel 1989 doveva essere
l’anno della caduta di tutti i muri.
Doveva essere
l’inizio della globalizzazione.
Eppure siamo qui, 35 anni dopo,
e sappiamo bene che non è andata così.
Anzi, ad oggi, se andate, se vi guardate
intorno, se guardate nel mondo,
i muri sono quadruplicati.
Dappertutto si alzano muri
e si combattono guerre per un muro,
guerre per una frontiera.
E speriamo di no,
ma in futuro potrebbero combattersi
guerre anche per frontiere extraterrestri
o frontiere sommerse.
Il mio auspicio, naturalmente, è quello
che non vada a finire così.
Sopra le nostre teste,
questo perché sopra le nostre teste,
ma anche sotto i fondali oceanici,
nel fondo degli oceani,
ci sono ricchezze che non hanno prezzo,
per cui potenze, superpotenze,
potenze in tutto il mondo
cercano e rivendicano
porzioni di territorio.
E lo fanno appunto
piantando bandierine.
Due superpotenze hanno già piantato
bandierine sulla Luna.
Un’altra lo ha già fatto qualche anno fa
sul fondale del Mare Artico.
E’ la Russia, a 4000 metri di profondità
per rivendicare appunto
porzioni di territorio che
conservano, racchiudono
ricchezze inestimabili.
Appunto, negli ultimi cinquant’anni,
come vedete, è cambiato tutto.
Diciamo dall’inizio dell’era spaziale,
della fine degli anni 50 ad oggi
e in particolare dal 1967,
quando fu definito
il primo trattato dalle Nazioni Unite
per lo spazio extraatmosferico,
dove le risorse
vennero definite inappropriabili.
Oggi, in virtù dello Space Act americano,
queste risorse dall’essere inappropribili
sono diventate sfruttabili.
Questo da qualche anno,
dal, credo, 2019, 2018.
Eppure la globalizzazione, il cambiamento
climatico e la recente pandemia
avrebbero dovuto farci capire che
il concetto di muro e di frontiera
è totalmente inefficace
di fronte a processi geologici,
processi socioeconomici
come le migrazioni, processi sanitari,
come le pandemie.
Più ci allontaniamo dalla superficie
terrestre, più il concetto di confine
si mostra insignificante ed è sempre più
chiaro che tutto è interconnesso.
E nonostante tutto, però,
le divisioni restano.
In un mondo dove l'uomo è la principale
forza geologica, i confini e le decisioni
politiche possono condizionare fortemente
e profondamente il sistema Terra.
Pensiamo ad una risorsa come l'acqua e
pensiamo anche a tutte le morfologie
associate all'acqua.
Pensiamo ai fiumi, pensiamo ai laghi,
pensiamo ai bacini idrici,
che siano naturali o che siano
artificiali, come ad esempio le dighe.
E a tal proposito pensiamo a
un’opera immensa, un’opera faraonica
che è stata iniziata nel
2011 e conclusa poco fa,
che è La Grande Diga Etiopica.
Queste opere, se gestite bene,
possono portare molti vantaggi.
Se invece gestite male, a causa appunto
dei confini e quindi non coordinate con
i paesi a valle, come nel caso specifico,
possono essere il Sudan o l’Egitto,
l’Etiopia, sì, potrebbe trarne grandi
vantaggi e grandi benefici da quest’opera,
ma il Sudan e l’Egitto potrebbero avere
grandi problemi,
appunto grazie alla mancanza
di coordinazione dovuta ai confini.
Questo in termini di minori apporti
d'acqua e di minori apporti di sedimenti
che quindi condizionano
tutti gli ambienti geologici
a valle di questa di questa diga.
I processi geologici e il sistema Terra
di cui la nostra specie è solo uno
dei moltissimi attori come vedete appunto
non conoscono il concetto di confine.
Come dicevamo all’inizio, il concetto
di confine naturale fu introdotto
dai colonizzatori
alla fine del XVIII secolo all’incirca
e fu applicato
in maniera particolare ai fiumi.
E, pensate, che al giorno d’oggi
i confini politici segnati nel mondo
dai fiumi sono dal 25 al 30% circa.
Come vedete, la maggior parte dei confini
politici segnati da grandi fiumi sono
nel Sud America.
l’Asia è il continente
che ne ha meno in assoluto
e questo ha una spiegazione storica
perché il Sud America
è stato colonizzato
in maniera importante
dagli imperi occidentali.
l’Asia no, ad eccezione
del sud-est asiatico, dove Francia,
Inghilterra in particolare, sono rimasti
fino alla fine del XX secolo.
Tuttavia, proprio i fiumi ci mostrano
che i confini mutano in continuazione,
fino in alcuni casi
a sparire proprio.
Se guardiamo in maggior dettaglio
la geologia terrestre,
ci accorgiamo appunto che se ne infischia
totalmente delle nazioni
e capiamo subito
che le barriere geologiche
non sono mai per sempre.
Pensiamo al caso del confine
tra Arkansas e Mississippi.
Il confine tra Arkansas e Mississippi
negli Stati Uniti
è stato disegnato 150 anni fa e seguiva,
come vedete
la linea viola, che vedete in alto,
seguiva il corso del fiume.
Tuttavia, il corso del fiume
non è mai lo stesso
negli anni,
nei decenni, nei millenni.
Questo in particolare un fiume
che ha meandrizzato, cioè ha curvato molto
e quindi si è discostato molto
da quello che era
il corso originario
circa 150 anni fa.
Questo è un caso proprio che ci mostra
che appunto i confini, soprattutto
quelli geologici, non sono eterni,
ma mutano e sono in continuo divenire.
Se ci spostiamo più a sud e andiamo a
un confine internazionale come quello tra
Stati Uniti e Messico,
questo è il Rio Grande.
Il Rio Grande è un fiume
che più si avvicina alla costa,
più tende a meandrizzare, proprio come
il Mississippi che abbiamo visto prima.
Il confine è stato disegnato
seguendo l’attuale corso del Rio Grande,
ma se vedete qui giù, sopra
Jesus Vega Sanchez, c’è un antico meandro,
un’antica curva
del fiume del Rio Grande,
che adesso è migrato verso nord.
Si è spostata, è curvato.
Adesso definisce il confine
tra Stati Uniti e Messico.
Questo confine
naturalmente evolverà, migrerà
e se ne infischia
di quello che noi decidiamo.
Se ci spostiamo ancora più a sud,
siamo al confine tra Bolivia e Cile.
Il confine tra Bolivia e Cile
è stato definito seguendo
quelle che sono cime vulcaniche.
Anche qui non è un confine geologico,
è un confine che non è,
e non sarà mai eterno.
In altri luoghi della terra la geologia
e le sue morfologie definiscono che
i confini sono
ancora più evidenti.
È il caso qui
della catena himalayana.
Questa barriera topografica segna
il confine tra diversi stati.
Anche questo, che a voi può sembrare un
confine immobile, fermo, si sposta,
è mobile ed evolverà nel tempo,
naturalmente su scala geologica.
Ma è la prospettiva geologica che tutti
noi dovremmo adottare quando approcciamo
a decisioni che non riguardano
una singola nazione o un singolo popolo.
Se ci fermiamo quindi a riflettere,
guardiamo anche al passato,
è molto chiaro che il concetto di confine
è astratto e totalmente primitivo.
Pensiamo ad una nazione
come la Nuova Zelanda.
La Nuova Zelanda è lontana
più di 2000 chilometri dall’Australia,
eppure anche qui l’uomo è arrivato,
accompagnato dai suoi mammiferi.
Questo cosa ci insegna?
Ci insegna che come specie
non guardiamo molto i confini fisici.
Se vogliamo andare da qualche parte,
lo facciamo e basta.
Non importa che dobbiamo scalare montagne
o attraversare oceani e questo
è uno degli aspetti più emozionanti,
più straordinari della specie umana.
Quindi, se guardiamo il mondo adottando
una prospettiva geologica, allora capiamo
che tutti i confini che cerchiamo di
stabilire oggi, prima o poi svaniranno.
La tettonica delle placche è spietata,
l’erosione altrettanto,
la deposizione anche.
Le attuali montagne svaniranno
e altre ne verranno su.
I fiumi continueranno a scorrere finché
avranno un rilievo alle loro spalle,
erodendo tutto quello che incontrano e
seppellendolo nel fondo degli oceani.
Il modo in cui dividiamo il mondo,
sia fisicamente che geologicamente,
è totalmente temporaneo.
Quindi, se vogliamo guardare bene questa
immagine, se vogliamo davvero affrontare
e provare a vincere sfide globali come
il cambiamento climatico, le migrazioni e
le pandemie, solo per citarne alcuni,
l’unico modo è agire e pensare come
un unico popolo e un’unica specie
che abita sull’unico posto nell’universo
conosciuto fino ad oggi,
che è in grado di ospitare la vita.
E di questo posto, quel posto che ben
8 miliardi di persone chiamano casa,
siamo chiamati tutti a prendercene cura,
perché ad oggi è l’unica casa che abbiamo.
Grazie.
[Applausi]